ähm also noch mal ein ganz harter Themen
cut es geht jetzt um das Thema
Bürgergeld das Bürgergeld ist eines der
Top Themen im Deutschen Bundestag es gab
schon eine Reihe von Debatten in der
nächsten Woche steht das Thema wieder
auf der Tagesordnung des Deutschen
Bundestages und ich habe festgestellt
und viele meiner Kollegen auch ist dass
die ampelregierung äußerst dünnhäutig
auf Kritik am Bürgergeld reagiert um es
vielleicht vorweg zu sagen wir als Union
sehen das Bürgergeld kritisch es ist
nicht zielführend es ist ungerecht und
das sendet die völlig falschen Signale
und jetzt könnte man meinen ja es
verwundert nicht unbedingt dass die
Opposition nicht die Meinung der
Regierung teilt was wir aber beobachten
ist dass unsere Kritik und auch die
Kritik von anderen in der Öffentlichkeit
moralisch abgewertet wird also da ist
dann ganz schnell die Rede von Hetze und
Populismus sind darauf aufmerksam
gemacht wird dass beispielsweise mit der
bürgergeldreform eine gewisse
Ungerechtigkeit geschaffen wird dass
Menschen die niedr Einkommen haben nur
noch kaum oder kaum mehr Geld zur
Verfügung haben am Ende des Monats mit
Vollzeitjob als jemand der ein
Bürgergeld bezieht und nicht arbeiten
geht nach Abzug aller Kosten allein
schon das darauf aufmerksam machen wird
kritisiert moralisch abgewertet und als
Hetze gebrandmarkt und ich finde diese
Art von Debatte die da geführt wird also
das gesagt wird das Kritiker nach unten
treten sozial kalt sind ich finde dass
das hilft nicht der Debatte im Gegenteil
wir sollten sachliche Argumente
austauschen und ich finde auch die Ampel
muss sich diese Kritik gefallen lassen
denn am Ende des Tages fühlen sich sonst
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger mit ihrer
Kritik vielleicht nicht gehört im
Deutschen Bundestag absolut dafür mich
heißt wie sehen Sie das denn ist das
Bürgergeld unfair ist es ungerecht wie
stehen Sie dazu also ich kann da
politisch nichts dazu sagen es ist gar
nicht mein Mandat als Menschenrechtler
aber trotzdem kann ich doch sagen wir
sind
am meisten Länder der Welt und es gibt
in Deutschland so eine große Armut dass
die Tafeln die auf einer freiwilligen
Hilfe basieren gar nicht mehr hinterher
kommen so das kann man sich doch nicht
mehr leisten das heißt also wie wollen
wir die Menschen weiter ernähren wie
wollen wir Ihnen ob das es gibt auf
jeden 500.000 freie Jobs aktuell in
Deutschland 1,9 Millionen
1,9 Millionen deswegen sagen wir ja dass
wir aber da sind auch befristete drunter
und Mangel haben ja aber Fakt dass sie
sind offen und wir haben
Arbeitskräftemangel überall und deswegen
ist genau das ja das falsche Signal
jetzt sollte es doch oberste Priorität
sein die Menschen wieder stärker in die
Jobs zu bekommen die Beratung zu
verbessern das was die Ampel aber macht
ist da die Mittel zu kürzen in der
Beratung übrigens haben die haben sie
genau das gerade gemacht was ich
kritisiert habe sie haben das auch so
eine soziale moralische Ebene gezogen
als ob wir sozusagen mit unserer Kritik
am Bürgergeld nicht möchten dass die
Menschen sozial abgesichert sind ganz im
Gegenteil ich die argumentiere nie
moralisch also das ist das ist also da
ist die soziale Not wenn die Menschen
auf Tafeln sind schon so weit dass es
ein Menschenrecht betrifft nämlich ein
Menschenrecht auf Ernährung auf
Gesundheit und einen Menschenrecht auch
auf wohnen vielleicht finden wir deinen
Mittelweg frau Klein sie sind ja Berlin
Mitte das haben sie heute auch schon der
Sendung gesagt
wie teuer ist in Berlin Mitte aktuell
eine Wohnung und super teuer super teuer
das heißt wie viele Aufstocker wird es
dann auch in Zukunft geben bei den Jobs
ist das vielleicht das Problem was
eigentlich die Ampel angehen muss
also das mietenthema ist tatsächlich
noch mal ganz anderes Thema aber Fakt
ist dass eben genau bei dieser Debatte
um das bürgergerät ist genau darum geht
wie es es eigentlich ausgestaltet also
das schon Vermögen ist sehr hoch
angesetzt 150.000 Euro für eine
vierköpfige Familie wer hat so viel Geld
auf der hohen Kante es geht doch beim
Bürgergeld und bei Hartz IV ging es doch
immer darum den Bedürftigen zu helfen
den Menschen die auf Hilfe angewiesen
sind
Beratung und Hilfe zukommen zu lassen
damit sie es wieder auf eigene Beine
schaffen die die können die die nicht
können ist eine ganz andere Frage aber
die die können und darum geht es und die
Bedürftigkeit ist einfach bei vielen
Dingen die jetzt geändert werden nicht
mehr gegeben also eine Anspruchshaltung
der Staat würde schon richten die förder
des Bürgers könnte daraus folgen ja dass
das kann passieren aber das das muss
nicht sein und deswegen sagen wir ja als
Union das ist da Nachbesserungsbedarf
gibt deswegen haben wir auch als in den
Bundesländern vom Bundesländer Seite aus
Nachbesserungen gefordert für die
bundesratsverhandlungen also
dass unsere Position und ich glaube dass
am Ende des Tages geht es auch um das
Gerechtigkeitsempfinden der Menschen
gerade die die 40 Stunden die Woche
arbeiten die jeden Tag zur Arbeit gehen
es ist nicht vermittelbar dass jemand
der in Vollzeit arbeitet und nur wenig
mehr raus bekommt als jemand der nicht
arbeitet das als gerecht zu definieren
lesen Sie hier mehr mit ihrer Partei
zufrieden bei der Landwirtschaft waren
es ja nicht da waren sie ja nicht so auf
Frau Kleins Nenner gehen Sie jetzt mit
ich gehe mit und ich finde ich finde es
auch gut dass frau Klein jetzt gesagt
hat wir haben kein Fachkräftemangel den
haben wir sowieso aber wir haben vor
allem ein Arbeitermangel es gibt ja
keinen mehr gucken Sie mal in der
Landwirtschaft als Beispiel sie finden
doch keinen mehr kein deutschen der
spargelsticht also grundsätzlich muss
ich Arbeit natürlich lohnen dass der
Sinn muss glaube ich hier alle einig
aber grundsätzlich muss man natürlich
auch die Leute die ich sag's mal bewusst
sich zu Hause ist gemütlich machen in
der sozialen Hängematte davon kenne ich
persönlich auch welche die gibt's normal
sagen sie können das doch nicht sagen
sie
aber ich nicht und deswegen ist ja die
Wahrheit es gibt genügend die sich da
gemütlich machen und ich war hier in
Berlin bis 2010 Polizeibeamter ich war
da selbst in den Häusern gesehen wie die
leben und dass die fühlen sich da
wunderbar und die muss man einfach mal
wieder in die Arbeit kriegen weil es
genau wie sie sagen diejenigen die in
einem niedlich Lohn oder im mittleren
lohnsegment unterwegs sind die die
können doch die Hände nur im Kopf
zusammenschlagen dass die Arbeiten gehen
und am Ende 150 € vielleicht am Meer
Monat haben das ist doch nicht gerecht
ich bin ein sozial eingestellter Mensch
ich liebe diesen Sozialstaat aber der
muss auch bezahlt werden und du musst
auch langfristig bezahlt werden da
kommen Kosten auf uns zu ich weiß gar
nicht wie dieser Staat das alles wissen
will und da muss man Leute in Arbeit
kriegen das ist einfach so
also ich wohne in der Nähe vom Bahnhof
Zoo und wenn ich mir da die vielen
bedürftigen anschaue die von der
Bahnhofsmission Essen bekommen und
Kleidung bekommen dann sind das nicht
unbedingt Leute die fähig sind zu
arbeiten okay Leute die haben deswegen
habe ich das gesagt die die können das
ganze ist unterscheiden klar jeden aber
da gibt's doch sie müssen doch zustimmen
oder meinen Sie allen Ernstes dass er
alle drin sitzen 2,4 Millionen
Arbeitslose davon sind ja die die
Maßnahmen sind und die Sozialhilfe am
Finger sind gar nicht mitgezählt dass
sie alle nicht arbeiten können
vielleicht wollen auch einige nicht
arbeiten und da muss man schon gewissen
Anreiz haben weil die anderen die
bezahlen Harald wie nehmen sie die
Stimmung in dem Land war
ich fahre mich gerade über was wir reden
reden wir konkret über das Bürgergeld
oder reden wir über die Debattenkultur
wie gehen wir miteinander um wie wie
diskutieren wir wird wenn Sie mehr ein
Halbsatz sage ich falsch sagen der mir
nicht passt sind schlechter Mensch so
empfinde ich im Moment viele
Diskussionen und das halte ich für den
Demokratie eine Katastrophe ich glaube
wir reden seit wir angefangen am vorhin
über Katha um ab über Abwägung weil wir
unsere Meinung äußern dürfen anders wo
ist das nicht so schmerzlos zu haben
das ist Demokratie an der Abwägung und
ich bin völlig bei Ihnen wenn ein Land
wie Deutschland bei all dem Problem ist
heute gibt eine solche armutquote hat
das ist ein Skandal seine Katastrophe
absolut ein menschliche Katastrophe aber
ja es gibt auch andere Dinge über die
muss man reden und das ist dann euer Job
abhängig und ja genau ich bin nicht kein
schlechter Mensch wenn ich mir ein
Fußballspiel angucke bei dieser Karte WM
aber jeder der es nicht möchte ich
möchte nur im Gespräch bleiben und zwar
ein Gespräch über über vielleicht hast
du an der stelle mir recht da das ist so
habe ich Demokratie immer verstanden und
am Ende muss es irgendeine Lösung geben
die so nah wie möglich am Optimum ist
nicht mehr und nicht weniger aber so wie
das zurzeit in vielen läuft und wir
bewegen uns dann so auf die Trump wenn
wir mit dem Finger auf trampoo die USA
gezeigt wie die wie wie da das Land
gespalten wird und wie es nur noch gute
und schlechte gibt und zwar leider
beiderseits auch Herr Ralf das war ein
wunderschönes Schluss Plädoyer ich werde
mir das nachher sogar noch mal
aufschreiben das war auf den Punkt genau
das was wir eigentlich auch mit Final
Art erreichen wollen